If you're still here,
I'll assume that means that
you've decided that you
are ready to take this course.
And in which case I'll say again,
welcome to educational technology.
I'm really glad to have you here.
But before we get started
with this course,
there's something that's very
important to understand.
This is a course about
educational technology, but
it's also very much an experiment
in educational technology.
I know of other courses online
that have a lot of discussions or
are built around projects.
But I don't know of any that go
quite as far as we're going to go.
This is really an experiment to see
what educational technology can do.
We're going to try some things in
this course that will fail miserably.
We're also going to try some things
that will work out really well and
that we should implement in
other courses going forward.
Part of your role as a student in this
course is to give us feedback on that.
What's working?
What's not?
What should we fix and what should
we carry on into other courses?
That's part of your
participation in this class.
The learning goals of this
class are to learn about
what educational technology can do.
And so you need to give us feedback on
what educational technology is doing.